I want to introduce some new technology
we are trying out we're always trying to
have cutting-edge technology on our
program and I think today we have really
hit a homerun this is a device called
the Andy head camera now here's how it
works
basically this is a camera that Andy
wears on his head once you put that on
right now Andy and you're gonna see for
the first time from Andy's point of view
what he sees how he sees it when he sees
it and why he sees it right how does it
work well it's a camera that I wear on
my head I can like pop in at any time
and you can see button yeah that's so
you override the director I do like this
ya know it's what I want
yeah me
move Wow Wow
there's a lot of anger coming out of you
right now this is my turn mine you see
what I see all right
hey take it easy pal I should say this
you know it seems easy yeah but I had to
wear it around today to kind of get used
to it
Oh des Pratt yeah yeah exactly I
actually took some videotape of you
wanna see okay I'll be there in a second
your pretty girl
yeah I thought I'd check out your
dressing room yeah all right well I'm a
very pretty girl you are you are very
pretty
let's talk about tonight's show started
the NBC series community and host of
ease the soup our good pal Joel McHale
tomorrow we're not like five minutes
into the show oh okay you know you
didn't know that they do that every
night I I suspected you seemed way too
happy over there